It's funny how the world has different
time zones,
how it could be Saturday on this side of
the world and Friday somewhere else.
Yet somehow, the United States of America
is stuck in 1920.
That was a hundred years ago,
yet we're still fighting for our lives,
for a place here.
What did we ever do to make them hate us
so much?
I know for a fact they love our culture.
They love to steal our braids, the way we
talk,
anything we call ours.
But when it's that one white
bad cop and that one innocent Black
person,
that Black person fears for their life.
This is the world we live in.
See, when I was younger, teachers used to
ask kids what they wanted to be when
they grew up.
Some kids said "famous." I was one of those
kids.
But now I change my answer. The thing I
want to be when I grow up
is alive.
How do i know that I'm going to make it
out alive if I'm suspicious doing
nothing?
If I'm suspicious when I'm at my own
house sleeping in my own bed.
Why am I suspicious? Because I could have
sworn from one to three I was the cutest
thing.
But when did I stop being cute and
start being scary?
Am I scary if I have a black hoodie? Am I
scary if I wear a backpack?
Am I scary if I do nothing?
Am I scary? Does my dad scare you?
Does my mom scare you? Does my auntie scare you?
Because let me tell you something: we are not scary.
Say their names. You will earn my respect
when I don't have to fear for my life
or anybody else's.
Until then, my respect will not come for free.